[Music]
[Music]
everybody I just need a document this is
mere international I didn't have a dog
[ __ ] bag thing that protects your Hannah
yes girl yes I got an orange I got mixed
nuts
I got hummus this what's the deal this
aesthetic that you have going today I
don't know what happened it's
unbreakable I don't know
I know that was a show for you to focus
camera I totally get it
good morning it is Friday morning it is
like 8:30 a.m. I have to get ready to go
over and shoot six more episodes of this
might get today but you know sometimes
in the morning you get distracted
because you make yourself spaghetti for
breakfast
relatable laughs I made myself some
spaghetti now I'm running late so let's
go over to the sack okay here's my
problem
I don't think through the episodes um
this might get that we are shooting on
the days of your shooting them because I
just remembered as I am driving now that
we have this woman that Maher and I have
not met but she is an Eastern medicine
specialist and she is coming in to do
some examinations analyses on memory and
I just gonna look at like our tongue and
our eyes and our hands and stuff like
that tell us like what our health status
is she got no ID forget II for breakfast
she got annoyed
I hate tequila for dinner last night oh
I mean you want to be an Eastern
medicine specialist to figure that one
out yeah I did not set myself up for
success for this episode all right so
the other thing that is happening today
is I'm bringing in this banana bed with
me finally I mentioned this on an
episode of this might get but I bought
this banana bed on Amazon for goo
months ago because it was recommended to
me on Amazon I'm easily persuaded and
she doesn't sleep in it he's a little
too small for her she also thought it
was a toy and so she was trying to rip
it apart and I told her no and so then
she got I think oh wow you can't see me
at all
she just has never slept in it she's a
little too big for it and she initially
thought it was a toy so she started
eating it and I told her no so I think
she assumes that I think she shouldn't
be near it
in some capacity and so she's just never
used it she's been in my house I thought
who can I give this to Eureka beans
beans on set with us so much so I was
gonna bring it to set last week but
suddenly when I put it next to my bag of
stuff to bring with me to set all of a
sudden a little critter got in there
yeah goose was just sitting in this bed
voluntarily for the first time ever
since I bought it so I didn't take what
to set with me that day and so she has
the sense sat in it not once
she hasn't even gone near it so I'm
attempting to bring it to 70 today to
see if Queen beans has any connection to
it I doubt it
expectations are low but the yellow will
match with our set so that's all good is
bringing our key talent to set did you
think this
she has been presented things are
getting okay what is Fraggle it's just
doing her best
hi blog thing that's happening here it's
Sunday
you might be thinking grace what
happened to your Saturday you didn't
document any of it that's right you're
correct and kind of judgmental and a
little blurry
hold on no I did not document any of my
Saturday because I watching the new
queer quit whoa I can't say it because
it's too holy and pure I'm just too good
for this world I started watching the
new season of queer I if you guys
haven't seen it on Netflix not even an
ad or plug or anything well it's a plug
but on my own accord it's so good I
watched the entire season and then I
just started redoing my whole house and
these are four bags of shoes that I'm
donating because I cleaned out my closet
- I've just been this room got totally
changed I put my what was my dining room
table in there as my desk now I'm gonna
work on that who's also in there if you
haven't seen it yet I highly recommend
it
it's unbelievable it's not just some
fluffy makeover show they talk about
like real societal cultural
interpersonal issues on a very um not
in-your-face it's a very genuine and
real way that makes you just want to
have conversations with anyone you don't
have closure with and fix it all up head
to toe inside it out I can't say enough
good things about it so my whole
Saturday went to that and now it's
Sunday I've gotta get ready because may
mean I go to New York City tomorrow
morning to basically talk in front of a
bunch of advertisers and beg them to
give us money to produce better quality
and more episodes if this might get just
gonna go try to sell our little Souls
for a little bit of money let's do it we
came to the park
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ha I look like spy no I look like a scum
that just got off a plane we made it to
New York City a hotel room tour Wow Wow
cute and what's the first thing you do
when you get to your hotel room in New
City you get a goddamn dirty vodka
martini up with olives my friend Hey Oh
yikes calm
now there's 650 am yeah sorry department
started out and Natasha who stole my
makeup before it's coming to do my hair
makeup because memory and I are doing a
press day we're just doing a couple
interviews at a couple different places
let's order coffee your nose
good morning come on they are vlogging
now that they know what they're doing
it's as if they're BuzzFeed
okay we just played a fun game where we
got a drink from a giant bottle of wine
and a giant Cup they know I'm going to
Sirius Radio them and if I get Syria
okay it's a quick stop for a lot eight
nine ten eleven we did it I'm back
memory and I didn't event the main event
that we were supposed to be out here for
which was that we had to go speak to
advertisers and try and beg them to give
us their Monday so we could keep doing
episodes this might get and we just did
that this morning it was just thrilling
now I'm back in my room got a pack I'm
going to go to Us Weekly and do an
interview with them and then we're gonna
try to get on a flight home our flight
was canceled because of this snow but we
got a new flight that we're hoping
fingers crossed actually applies packing
up my room right now aka having a glass
of red wine and some top chips I can't
stop being on Brad okay I'm officially
changed into of my giving up office
outfit for this last interview and I
just realized the woman who did my hair
this morning was so kind and she knew
that my hair needed a trim until she
trimmed it so I'm leaving this hotel
room with just like some hair on the
floor there's gonna be some questions
about what happened in this hotel room
after I leave let's go get him on the
flight
[Music]
the first time - I cannot put it this
actually we're moving and again David
let's do this
hour and a half it's just been asleep
with her legs been asleep like the
disapproving stepmom with no explanation
as to what to do it's not this smoke
alarm it's this weird
was my FBI agent reaching out oh my god